when teresa shu asked a beijing hospital
to help freeze her eggs to later enable
her to have a child as a single parent
she was turned away
as an unmarried woman she's denied
reproductive services in china
in 2019 she filed a lawsuit to change
the law and her case has been heard in
court
i don't have much time to waste i'm an
ordinary single woman and these past
three years were very important to me if
i win i hope i can help other women to
save years of their life in the future
in china if single women want to have
their ex frozen they can do it
the case is the first of its kind in
china and sparked debate over women's
right to reproduce
china's health commission says freezing
eggs is risky and unreliable and the ban
is designed to prevent companies from
exploiting the technology but activist
jung allan says it's discriminatory as
single men are allowed to freeze their
sperm
she's petitioned members of the
parliament the national people's
congress asking them to rewrite
fertility regulations
the ability to give birth shouldn't be
connected to being married as a
precondition it shouldn't be restricted
by policy
teresa shu and her supporters are
optimistic the judge will rule in their
favor china is facing a demographic
crisis and the government is desperately
trying to boost the country's birth rate
china's population is rapidly aging and
fewer babies are being born every year
beijing announced a three-child policy
in may but government support is limited
to couples
some women have traveled abroad to
access egg freezing and ivf services
but expensive fees and pandemic travel
restrictions mean this option is out of
reach for most including teresa
if i have to borrow the money from
friends or relatives or get loans from
the bank it goes against my original
intention which is being able to choose
my lifestyle and not be forced to marry
someone in order to have a child
she's awaiting the judge's verdict and
says she'll continue to raise awareness
of her case regardless of the outcome
katrina u al jazeera beijing